[Musique]
dans le cirque de cilaos les termes
accueille les curistes dans un
environnement exceptionnel depuis 1987
la qualité des eaux thermales
cilaosienne reconnu le département a
donc souhaité valoriser et développer
cet établissement de pur
rôle de poursuivre justement les
développements de l'établissement
thermal donc que jackson la stratégie
sur trois axes principaux de la
rénovation de la partie
curé partie bien-être avec l'acquisition
de nouveaux matériels
tel que le lead roma sans le sauna
l'embellissement du parc
et puis
fidéliser la clientèle de
la passante l on peut dire de curistes
en proposant de nouvelles cures et de
nouvelles orientations et aussi une
nouvelle offre au niveau de la partie
médicale donc nous avions déjà les
orientations rhumatologie pour tout ce
qui est art rose nous avons la partie
orientation digestives et troubles
métaboliques et là nous avons accès aux
nous avons créé une cure ugtg abete avec
des ateliers supplémentaires ateliers
diététiques
un coach sportif en côte mondiale mental
et aussi des conseils infirmiers un
centre de cure thermale et de remise en
forme qui propose de nombreuses
prestations dont sa femme la compagnie
d' actes de kinésithérapie
j'ai beaucoup de personnes et beaucoup
de curistes que voilà il me parle de ses
problèmes qu'ils ont ils déjà une
sciatique ont été limités à l'époque ils
ont marre d'eau donc forcément il a tout
ce côté il faut voilà de savoir au
niveau de la note remise avec manet mon
expérience mon expérience au niveau
professionnel comme kiné je peux les
aider aussi je peux le donner des
conseils
après des soins qui vous peut faire
aussi chez eux comme des étirements des
postures voilà pour eux pour être au
bout que de soins et la pure ça soit au
plus efficace possible
une équipe de professionnels à l'écouté
de la santé des curistes pour des soins
efficaces et un séjour agréable on les
accompagne du vestiaire au bal bas dure
20 minutes
d'abord elle passe chez l'infirmière si
besoin est
elles font le le bain ça dure 20 minutes
il ya le bain hydromassant dix minutes
et là et robin 10 minutes puis quand
elle sort du ben nous on nettoie les
baignoires et on les accompagne vers
d'autres soins c'est-à-dire la douche
roger
la douche colonnes ou le massage et
ensuite il ya les katas place tout se
fait avec de l'eau thermale
elle est à 37 degrés les thermes de
cilaos désigne le plus petit
établissement thermal de france est le
seul de la zone océan indien
[Musique]